-Which was disappointing
because we were --
we were both
at the Met ball on Monday,
and I didn't see you.
-Not once.
-It's very crowded,
and there's a lot of people.
-It's hectic.
It's celebrity-rich.
-It is celebrity-rich.
The theme was camp,
and you and your co-star
from "Girls," Jemima Kirke
you guys looked fantastic.
Do you want to talk throug
how you guys
came up with these outfits
[ Cheers and applause ]
Really...
-Thank you.
-...really good stuff.
-I have to say
that we came to slay,
and I think that we took home --
I think we secured the bag
as the kids would say.
-You slayed so much,
the cops were waiting
for you guys when you left
-Well, here's what
I'll tell you.
I do have to give credit
to the designer,
Christopher Kane,
and my stylist, Chris Horan.
But the attitude is all ours
-Yeah.
And it's really
on display there.
-Yeah. I think that --
I think that what was nice
about this year for me
is that, you know,
a lot of the themes --
Like, I love the Met Gala,
because I love
the Metropolitan Museum of Art
-Yeah.
-I love "Vogue" magazine,
Anna Wintour.
It's aspirational.
It's sexy.
It's thrilling.
I'm actually a columnist
at "Vogue" magazine,
a beauty columnist,
which some people consider -
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
Very impressive.
-...consider ironic
because of how rarely
I leave my home.
[ Laughter ]
But what I liked about this year
was that a lot of --
You know, oftentimes I feel --
I wouldn't say, like,
glam is my area,
but camp I can do.
[ Laughter ]
-Camp was more
in your wheelhouse, yeah.
-Yeah, so, I felt like this wa
the one year where I was like,
"Oh, Kendall Jenner,
come into my house."
[ Laughter ]
-I should say,
one of the nice things --
And, you know, I think a lot
of people, very fairly,
have these, you know, notion
about what the Met ball is
but there are
a lot of glamorous people,
a lot of fabulous people.
There are also a lot of people
like you and I who --
Dominos had to fall
in a very specific way
for us to end up
at the Met ball.
-To arrive there.
-And so, you know, you end up --
You know, for me, you know
I got to sit with,
you know, Mindy Kaling
and Rachel Brosnahan,
and I think we're all
sort of --
We kind of can't believe
we're there.
and it makes for kind of
a cool night,
the amount of people
that you can talk to about like,
"What is happening
that we are here?"
-Totally.
[ Laughter ]
But Jemima and I
were pretty in the zone.
-Oh, you had a good night, then.
-Yeah, we were really in it.
Like, at the time I was like
"There has never been
a duo like us."
-Wow.
-We were walking up the stage --
We were walking up the stairs,
and, at one point,
we were feeling so good and so
glamorous and we're posing
and we had our poses planned
and we worked on it
in the hotel room before.
And we were like, "Okay,
we're gonna go back-to-back,
we're gonna go front-to-front,
we're gonna kiss on the lips
and shock them a little bit,
Britney and Madonna style.
We're gonna pull back and do a
little bit of cool glamour."
And then, literally,
we're walking,
and we hear this person go
"You're so brave!"
[ Laughter ]
And Jemima was like,
"What did they mean?"
And I was like,
"Oh, I know what they meant.
And now it's funny,
because at the time, I was like,
"There's never
been a team like this,"
and now I look, and I thin
what we look like in the photos,
in a positive way,
is when there's
a sexual-education video,
circa 7th grade,
and they animate two sperm
[ Laughter ]
Do you kind of see
what I'm talking about?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-I feel like --
-We were both like,
"Someone's getting
pregnant tonight."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And I feel like -- I don't
remember that from the videos,
but I feel like
that you're the good sperm
and she's the evil sperm.
-Yeah.
It's like, "This is a baby
that's gonna go to Harvard
and this is the baby that'
gonna sleep with your mom.
[ Laughter ]
And an amazing detail,
which I love because it's so -
Like, I have true respect fo
the entity of "Vogue" magazine
and what I love is that,
'cause it's so fashion
and so funny is that,
Jemima made the Best Dressed
list, and I did not.
-Really?
-But we're wearing
the same outfit.
So I don't know
if it was the shoes...
-Yeah.
-...the body...
-Oversight?
-...the spirit.
It's not an oversight.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm not mad.
Let's just say, I'm grateful
for what I can get.
It's my seventh year there
and I am not
gonna screw this up.
[ Laughter ]
My wife was burning me
because I made a list
that was Top 40
at the Met ball over 40.
[ Laughter ]
And there was a picture
of my wife and I,
and she was pretty mad,
'cause I'm 40 and she not.
[ Laughter ]
I'm dragging her.
-I love it.
-I'm dragging her up.
I'm dragging her up
into the dignified --
the dignity of age.
-I love it.
-You're not allowed to tak
photos inside the Met ball
-No.
-Although, I think very cool
people don't listen to that.
-No. But I'm not cool.
-Yeah.
-And I'm afraid.
-I'm a rule guy, as well.
-I'm a rule person.
And every time I --
Like, my favorite thing
is to break a rule,
then apologize profusely
and cry,
because I'm like,
"I didn't mean to,"
but I did -- I took one photo.
-Okay.
-But I feel okay about it,
because it was in the elevator
and I'm never going to share it.
-Great.
-But I can tell you about it
-Uh-huh.
You all may know
who Jared Leto is.
-Yep.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You want me to show the photo
or do you want to explain...
-Well, you know,
he's an iconic --
To me, he's iconic.
I mean, we know he's an actor.
He's a singer.
But to me,
he will always be
Jordan Catalano.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What is that?
"My So-Called Life."
-"My So-Called Life."
And that, for me, was really -
That was my sexual awakening
if you will.
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
-So, to see him --
And he ended up different
than I thought he would.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And, anyway, so at the Met,
he showed up carrying a --
-He went for it.
I do tip my cap.
-Oh, no.
I'm not judging.
He came with his own head.
[ Laughter ]
So, we're in the elevator.
He's with his friends.
I'm with my only friend.
And he's having --
And I tap him on the shoulder.
I'm like, "Excuse me."
And he's like --
And I'm like, "Can I borrow that
for one second?"
And he very willingly
handed me the head.
And I kissed it.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
And Jemima took the pictures
And Jemima was like,
"Tongue, touch it.
Hold it -- to the boob."
And then I gently
hand it back to him, like,
"Thanks so much for the lend."
[ Laughter ]
-That's very nice of him.
-Yeah.
-You asked for it the way othe
people ask for ChapStick.
-100%.
-[ Laughs ]